oh so this is one of my favorite songs
that I've ever written I'm really really
proud of it but I've never uploaded it
in its entirety onto YouTube before this
isn't the proper version this is a
ukulele acoustic version obviously as
you can tell from mr. ukulele chord
exterminate regenerates and I really
hope you like yet it's been such a long
time since I met you back home that if
one of us dies then the exterminate
regenerates I thought you always do
awful thing to just keep punting on
timing and leave me Monica
[Music]
we exterminate regeneration thought you
always knew our thing to just keep
fighting on tonight
once IQs time why don't you go to your
ship and leave me money we both carry
the fire that has the power Watsu and
life good one I do with that flame is
what separates odd times if it takes
till the end of reality to be a chip
that will be shown to meet you
[Music]
exterminate regeneration oh that it
isn't too late to win what seems
impossible even though I wrote that song
as part of my band chameleon circuit we
play songs about Doctor Who please don't
judge us if you liked it and you want to
listen to the other chameleon circuit
songs they are all on my website Charlie
McDonnell calm /music you can listen to
the entire chameleon circuit album for
free yes for free thank you for watching
and I will see you around the internet
bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool